just watch it enjoy it laugh at the  commercials Tim Tebow shares his Super  Bowl fifty plans as his former team the  Denver Broncos and Powell a Cam Newton  face-off  how will you be watching the game  tomorrow I'm not sure yet to be honest  with you is that bad I don't know we're  so busy yeah I was a couple events  beforehand and then maybe you still go  to the game if not probably just watch  it in the hotel okay with your brother  right yeah so have fun the former NFL  quarterback told et at the DirecTV Super  Saturday night party that he just wants  to catch up with old friends after a  busy football season and enjoy a good  game obviously I got a lot of friends  playing this game being a former Bronco  and then also I played with Cam so I'm  really rooting for him to finish off a  great season and he really did deserve  the MVP what you won tonight which is so  cool so I'm happy for him